okay it's Justine and today we're gonna
talk about vlogging with your phone I
feel like honestly if you are wanting to
make videos and you haven't made videos
before you don't have a camera or even
if you do have a camera most of you guys
have phones and even if it isn't the
newest model I guarantee that you can
get some incredible video and footage
from it this video was inspired by my
upcoming conference it's called vlog
universities I have an entire session at
vlog university dedicated to mobile
production so if you happen to be in Los
Angeles on January 31st through February
1st there's gonna be a really fun two
day workshop we're covering everything
that goes into creating content I'll put
a link in the description to vlog
University calm and be sure to use this
code at checkout for a discount a lot of
the rigs and accessories that I'm gonna
show you guys can be used for any phone
but obviously I'm gonna be using my
iphone to demo these I'm gonna show you
the first setup which is extremely easy
oh look the setup is done holding your
phone just like this to make sure that
you're in frame is one of the easiest
ways to start filming and making videos
with your phone you don't need anything
you just need this and you need to hold
your phone or have somebody else hold it
for you
the biggest tip though that I have and I
still make this mistake when you're
recording on the front facing of any
phones do not look at yourself on the
screen and this is the most difficult
thing to do so right now I am looking at
myself on the screen and it's so obvious
that I'm not looking at the lens so you
need to find the lens on whatever device
that you're filming with and look at it
this next setup is adding a tripod to
your phone which makes it so much easier
to hold there's a few different options
these are just two of the ones that I
use quite often I like this one because
it will clamp your iPhone very tightly
and you can also rotate it and it'll be
attached to a tripod already so you can
shoot in vertical or horizontal
depending upon what shot you're trying
to get you can use that a small tripod
this is great for time lapses or hyper
lapses or just straight-up vlogging like
I said it's great because you could also
shoot vertical you can use this for live
streams if you're doing like Instagram
Live or YouTube or whatever it is that
you do tick tocks I don't know this
obviously is a little bit bigger so if
you are looking for a smaller setup
that's where this little guy comes into
play these type of small metal clamps
can sometimes scratch your phone so I'd
like to make sure that I do have
a case on my phone I like this one a lot
just because it's very small super
compact and also very light so phones do
shoot really incredible video and audio
obviously there is room for improvement
so there's this little rig that I found
it's a cage made by small rig they make
so many amazing cages for cameras they
also even make them for your iPhone and
what's great about this is it's not just
for an iPhone so they have enough room
in here so you can fit any size phone my
recommendation is to put the volume
buttons up and make sure that there's
enough room at the bottom for the power
button so it doesn't turn on off and on
so I've done this just so that I have
access to the volume buttons lamps on
just like so this is metal it's pretty
high quality which is really nice it has
two cool shoe mounts right here on the
top and every single one of these little
holes small rig has a ton of accessories
you could attach so many different
things to this I'm not gonna overwhelm
you guys too much we're gonna keep it
simple we're gonna add a light and a
microphone and a tripod for this I'm
gonna switch out to a Benro small little
tripod here
I like this tripod a lot because you can
loosen this little blue ring and tighten
it and that gives you quick access to be
able to move around whatever you have on
top of it now we need a microphone I
actually got this one at the shore booth
this year at CES and this thing is
awesome so this came in a little kit in
this little rollup pouch it also came
with a little foam mount this one's also
really great because it has another cold
shoe attachment it's not looking you
just pop your little phone in here but
you can also mount their microphone I
really like this phone mount holder as
well but since we already have this rig
set up we're gonna try it with this
this microphone will also work with
Android it does have a USBC cable and it
comes with a lightning cable so since
i'm gonna be filming myself on the
front-facing camera i'm gonna be putting
the microphone over here facing towards
me and we just plug this in the film
will power the microphone this is just a
micro USB it's gonna weed this through
here there's an app on the phone that
connects to the microphone that gives
you access to all kinds of settings
right now the microphone is set to 60
degrees but you can go all the way up to
135 this will automatically be saved
onto the microphone so you don't have to
open this app every time so I think I'm
pretty happy with how my microphone is
set up but hmm it's a little dark in
here no it's not
let's just act like it is I think I need
a light for my setup also found these
guys at CES this is a company called
light draw look how small this little
guy is it's so incredibly cute and is
the perfect size for this mobile rig
this thing puts out a lot of light too
right now this is only on the low
setting medium high strobe this also has
little tiny filters look how many
different colors just even like a little
diffusion this thing even has a little
mini barn doors I don't have that
attachment but it's really cute this is
a bigger version of this one but I feel
like a mobile rig this is a little bit
heavier so this is something that I
probably would use more on a bigger
setup but if you do want more power and
more light man these are awesome what's
cool about this microphone is it does
have a headphone port so you can monitor
the audio and that'll also give you
access to the sound that's happening in
your phone and this is the internal
microphone on the iPhone obviously I
know what the sounds like because I
shoot a lot on my iPhone and it sounds
pretty good so here's a little audio
test using the short microphone and
obviously were kind of set up in a
studio setting here so the lighting is
already awesome but I am using the
little lighter light let me just show
you guys around a little bit
Tyler's over there and then we've got
some stuff over there that I'm showing
you guys what lights back here secret
stuff just hidden everywhere
[Music]
we decided to come out on a mini
adventure so that I could show you guys
some more of the things that I use for
mobile vlogging this is the DJI Osmo 3
this thing is awesome because it will
basically turn your phone into a
stabilizer there's even an app so inside
of the app you can do all kinds of
things like motion tracking motion
lapses can get some really incredible
stable and super steady shots even if
I'm running shy do a run test look how
steady it's so steady so another thing
that I love about this is it does have
the DDI software so you can do things
like tracking and Jenna draw a box
around me now I'm green so now if I move
it will track me I like this because if
you don't have another person to be able
to film for you you're able to track
yourself cool demo just seeing what's
gone
[Music]
Wow trying to rock home and film at the
same time not so great
you can good I dunno I'm in the shot
just got confirmation from five-year-old
that I'm in the shop hope this works out
[Music]
so mobile filmmaking I feel like as an
art because you don't really have that
much to work with if you basically have
a phone and whatever the phone can do
there's all kinds of fun attachments
like moment lenses this is actually a
moment case so these lenses will just
screw in and mount directly in front of
the iPhones camera lens I don't give you
all kinds of cool shots I have a macro I
have an int amorphic lens I have a fish
eye and a telephoto lens one of the big
comments that I read online is why would
you need to get some other lenses when
you have telephoto and wide-angle on the
iPhone well having this extra glass will
give you a much crisper look let me show
you the lenses and I will try not to
fall I'm gonna get on a little more
steady of ground this is a little case
it's so great because I can fit my Matic
Mini in here two batteries plus all of
my moment lenses this is a 14 millimeter
let's take a photo let's do some video
oh this looks incredible I tell you and
this is what I look like and I'm gonna
take a picture to show you the
difference between the wide-angle on the
iPhone the wide-angle on the moment lens
no here's the macro lens look at this
little guy it has this clear little
thing around it so we can show you how
close you need to be to something to
actually be in focus how does something
that you never will be able to do on
just the regular iPhone and just to
prove to you this shot it could not
happen here's the picture that I'm
taking with a regular phone so like it
will not focus not it happened macro is
cool for photos but unless you're doing
some really close-up macro video I
probably won't be using that video very
often unless I find some cool ants or
something here's some video using the
telephoto lens wow I'm so close up to
you look at that Peter mckinnon ND
filter looks so good here's me am I in
focus how does it close that's a really
close it's pretty close so I'm gonna set
a motion lapse using the DJI Osmo and
then I'm gonna pop
the anamorphic lens to get some really
cool shot
I have an injury just disregard my
bandage this is the anamorphic lens so
because this distorts your lens you have
to use a separate program so I've been
using filmic Pro it will take the
footage that this is filming and squeeze
it into the right aspect ratio so that
you can actually use it so I love filmic
Pro because it gives you access to
everything in the camera you can change
the color temperature the focus the ISO
the shutter speed it's like a real
camera I wish that I could get a lens
flare that Sun needs to pop back out
[Music]
the best part about in worship lenses
are the incredible insular so you can
see that I can go a little slower
[Music]
so that's it for this video I just want
to show you guys that you don't need a
lot of crazy accessories honestly if you
just have your phone and a creative mind
to go out and make some videos this is
really all that you need all these
accessories do just help you enhance
what you already have so just go out
start creating and I can't wait to see
what you guys make
bye are you asking me if this is the
best way to go down cuz I don't know if
it is John I came to pick us up
but I don't see her now going down going
down wow my car looks good over here dad
[Music]
oh my gosh what's up you see the pulp
over there they're really waiting to me
how do you know this is actually a
moment case you can tell there's little
screws right here inside of the oh god I
stopped raising as several different
lenses of a macro I have an anamorphic I
have a telephoto and knife freaking
forgot the other one
wide-angle fisheye T oh God